[Music]
hello mr rob lowe my name is trish kane
and i live in
southeastern michigan my friend andy uh
just shared with me a very interesting
link
to a video from the go-go
the song was turned to you and i see you
in that video it was very entertaining
could you please tell us more about that
experience thank you and have a good day
well trish thank you for calling me
you know
the question is
what rating do we want this story to
have do we want the nc 17 version or the
g rated version or the pg rate i those
are old ratings i don't even know if
they have those in movies anymore they
had them when i was
buying my tickets at eight dollars
um
the go-go's so when i was single
and
running my game i very much
loved me a good pop star
that was kind of my my jam
and
the gogos are a great band and super
talented
and i was more than happy to be the boy
toy of the go-go's
so
amongst hanging out with all the go-go's
they were like you need to be in this
video with us and i did and we shot it
at the grace graystoke mansion
which is this the a very famous location
in la big haunted old mansion right off
the sunset strip lots of
movies um have been filmed there there
will be blood the famous ending in the
bowling alley
is gray stoke mansion
um
i don't know what was happening with
that hair i should have been paying more
attention to it it's a lot of hair a lot
of hair spray and i think it was a the
go-go's were working out a um
their own real psycho drama with
the kathy valentine character and the
belinda character fighting over me in
the in the video i think was a little
bit of real life
um but it was super super fun and that
is more information than i was planning
on giving you when i started to answer
this question but you know what i don't
edit myself it's all truth here on
literally
thanks for calling in